hi I'm Matt Goldberg here with Collider
and I am in London for the Hobbes and
Shaw blu-ray the film is now available
on digital and will be available on 4k
blu-ray and DVD on November 5th
right now I'm in lovely Wembley Stadium
worthy Rams behind the powerful running
of Todd Gurley are going to take on the
Bengals who are technically a football
team while I'm here I'm also going to be
stopping by McLaren headquarters to race
some cars and I'm gonna be doing a bit
of stunt fighting where I will still
somehow get my ass kicked so I hope you
enjoy this video and stay tuned to
Collider we're now here at Silverstone
and I'm going to be driving the McLaren
720s it is by far the fastest car I have
ever been in in my life a far cry from
my hyundai elantra back home but we're
gonna be going around the track we're
gonna be going really fast which is
appropriate this is for a fast and
furious movie and what would that be
without the cars so I'm gonna be headed
into this and it should be a lot of fun
so I'm hopefully gonna drive it slightly
faster than I trust you to do that if
you go as fast as you like the wheel
[Music]
clock that they're 2:45
the speed without King the picture
vehicle coordinator for fast and furious
presents Hobbes and Shaw and one things
I wanted to ask you about so we're
working with you're working with these
vehicles right
what kind of did you have to make any
modifications for them to sort of get
them ready for the picture put in any
you know crash plates or anything like
that or these cars good to go off the
peg if you like man we they were pretty
much ready to go the only thing we did
do on two of them the stunt performers
we put hydraulic cam breaks in which is
it's a little bit funky to do on a
vehicle like this what's the process of
you know going through these kind of
lines of cars and finding what's right
for this movie the choice was pretty
much made because I'm Jason Statham was
quite keen that this is very Jason was
really keen on having one of these I
don't know the director had chosen it so
I kind of adopted the choice as far as
performance for for spent sequences it
gets a little bit more complicated
because over they have to almost do car
ballet right so it's either using rigs
or whatever modifications that we can do
which was the hydraulic handbrake with
the help of McLaren who gave us a
development ECU so they could open the
parameters on that which allowed us to
you know to do J turns and the handbrake
turns without the car you know
switching off or going into a safety
mode
[Music]
that's it now we're on the track so a
little bit more power down down this
straight okay I'm going to stay to the
right of this white line so in this
little tunnel that we're in this little
column yeah okay now okay so I like to
lean on the brake a little no I'm just
he's got so much more grip than you
think so yeah even need to break that
one okay then we're going to stay on the
right all the way down you can give us a
month you'll see how it feels a little
long straight
the brakes to straighten time
I can safely say don't do a car-chase
leave it to the professionals leave it
to the Hobbs and Shahs of the world not
people like me I'm not equipped for it
but great driving here quite an
experience let's go let's go see if I
can at least fight like Hobson shop
alright so now we're about to do a bit
of stunt work and before I get started
we're here with the stunt coordinator
and I just wanted to ask you what's it
like working with David on this since
with his background in stunt work um it
was amazing we actually grew up in the
stump business together we've known each
other for 25 years and and we pretty
much spent four years there we pretty
much spent every day together training
and getting to where we're at today in
our careers now we're going to be doing
the fight scene from the tattoo parlor
you talk a little bit about developing
that scene and what it was like sort of
constructing well we knew that this was
going to be kind of the opening to the
movie and so we have our two our two
lead characters Hobbs and Shaw and
they're very different in their styles
and their approaches to things and
Shaw's a little bit more refined a
little more skilled and Hobbs a little
bit more brute force in your face and so
that was kind of the path that we went
down when we were kind of choreographing
the fight
[Music]
you
[Music]
there I am an ice cold can of whoop-ass
[Applause]